-Welcome back. We're hanging out
with Kevin Hart right here,
the one and only!
Kevin Hart.
You're back
with Dwayne Johnson...
-Yes.
-in "DC League of Super-Pets."
Animated. Super-big movie.
It's out this Friday.
You guys are always great
together.
When did you know that you guys
were gonna be --
I mean, you guys are
in the history books together.
-You know what, man?
We -- We really --
We really do get along.
Like, it's a good relationship.
It's a genuine relationship.
And it was something
that we stumbled upon, right?
Like, we did our first movie
together,
and the conversations grew,
the friendship grew,
but it grew because
we were around each other.
Like, in between takes, we
weren't running to the trailer.
We were sitting, talking,
getting to know each other.
And we found that the scenes
became better
as we became closer, so we
kind of held onto that dynamic,
and it only progressed
as time went on.
-It's funny to watch you guys
even just do an interview,
and someone will say something
about the other person...
I mean, you can't mess
with Kevin Hart
if you're going to try to
outrank somebody.
But -- But he tries.
-He does all the time.
-Yeah, he does.
-He's not the smartest person.
He's not. He's not.
He's a genuine guy.
-Oh, my God. "A genuine guy."
-Genuine guy. Yeah.
-Yeah, no, I would say
he's pretty smart.
-He's not the brightest bulb
in the box.
-Oh, my God.
But that's what you guys do.
-Yes.
-And then -- But someone said --
They go, "You know, it's funny.
You play ping-pong with Kevin,
and you're like --
Oh, and he said
some mean stuff to you.
And then he'll just say
one nice, really..."
-One thing. One nice thing.
-"And you'll go,
'Oh, I love that dude.'"
-It's a Jedi.
The Jedi mind trick.
The Jedi mind trick,
all the time.
-So you guys did
the tortilla slap challenge.
-Yeah!
-I was afraid for you, Kevin.
-I slapped the [bleep]
out of him. Did you see it?
-No! No, no, no, no.
I was afraid for you.
-Oh. Oh, my God.
-Kevin Hart, I was afraid
for you, because I go --
'Cause you're -- you're ready to
do it, and then you're holding
the tortilla -- and if you
haven't seen it on TikTok,
you take a tortilla,
you drink a sip of water,
and you slap a tortilla
across someone's face.
-Yes.
-Dwayne's hand was behind this.
-Yeah, I had to make sure
he was holding it right.
-Yeah, 'cause he was holding --
He was gonna do this.
-No, I think he was gonna
try to smack --
I honestly think --
I think he wanted to kill me.
And I'm just being honest,
right?
Because he had his -- he had his
whole palm behind the tortilla.
I'm like, "No. No!
hat's not how you do it!"
-That's not
tortilla slap challenge.
-That's not the slap.
-You slap with the tortilla.
"You're just gonna slap me."
-And then he's like --
[Grunting]
'Cause that's how he talks.
-Alright. Yeah. This is --
-[Grunting]
-Now it's like Schwarzenegger.
What are you doing?
-[Grunting]
-Alright. Here -- This is --
This is you slapping Dwayne...
-Yeah.
-...with a tortilla.
-Yeah, you can't even --
The photo isn't even good,
'cause that's how fast I was
when I did it.
You know why I hit him so fast?
-Why?
-'Cause I felt like I had to
get out of there afterward.
[ Laughter ]
-This is him slapping you.
Look at his face.
-Yeah, no, look.
He's so -- I'm telling you!
I'm telling you, he's so evil.
Like, he's really --
Sometimes I think --
Sometimes I think
he wants to hurt me, man.
-Yeah, he wanted to draw blood.
-Yeah, like, that's --
Why is he --
Like, why is he like that?!
I've never seen --
I've never seen this photo.
-He got mad at you.
-This -- Look at this face!
-It's a tortilla --
It's a tortilla slap challenge.
-No!
-You don't make that face
when you slap someone
with a tortilla.
-He's biting down on his teeth.
Look!
You don't do that unless you
have real hate for somebody.
[ Laughter ]
I gotta call him about this.
-Yeah. Right? Yeah.
The movie's great.
It's good for kids.
-It really is.
-Great for adults, as well.
But, I mean, it's all DC,
all the superheroes, but pets.
-Yes.
-It's awesome, and it's funny.
I want to show everyone a clip.
-Here's Kevin Hart
and Dwayne Johnson
in "DC League of Super-Pets."
Take a look.
-Ha! Did you -- Ha ha ha!
You don't have your powers.
You're just trying
to use us now
'cause you can't
handle it on your own.
-I know these powers
are new to you,
but when one has
an abundance of power,
they have a certain duty
to use that power to...
[ Urinating ]
-Sorry.
You were saying something?
-I was making
an inspiring hero speech.
[ Urinating ]
How much did you have to drink?
-I had two toilet bowls
and a bidet.
Bidet, too, which is --
which is crazy.
I didn't even know
that was a thing,
but it's like
a dog water fountain.
-You disgusting animal.
-Pack, let's roll out.
I'll see you never.
-Yeah. "I had two toilet bowls
and a bidet."
-"And a bidet."
-Kevin Hart, everybody.
"DC League of Super-Pets"
is in theaters Friday.
Check out "Me Time" on Netflix,
beginning August 26th.
We'll be right back
with Joseph Quinn.
Stick around, everybody.